a learning organization encourages
personal mastery and cultivates open
feedback to see problems and
opportunities on all levels
some argue that learning organizations
attract and retain more talents others
say that there is a competitive
advantage for an organization whose
people learn faster than the people of
other organizations here are six
characteristics most have in common they
cherish an open culture learning
organizations encourage everyone to
share information admit to mistakes and
practice giving and taking constructive
criticism once the problem is found they
try to understand its root cause and fix
it to achieve such a culture walls are
removed information is shared and
leaders show their human sides they
design and implement feedback loops some
established 360 degrees surveys in which
people assess themselves their peers and
their bosses employees at 5-star hotels
ask guests for their opinions top
schools may videotape teachers so they
can later study themselves some even
make feedback a team effort before any
new project they all get together to
kick things off after the project they
meet again to share and reflect on what
has happened they promote personal
mastery employees try to achieve
personal mastery in their fields once
they become experts they feel proud of
their work they are motivated
intrinsically and they can create
positive change wherever they are for
example a cleaner might come up with an
idea on how to save water and an
accountant on how to save bank fees the
job of the boss
is to connect all experts and give
directions
they plan for intelligent fast failure
when they build something new they don't
spend time to make assumptions on paper
instead they create what's called
Minimum Viable Product a simple
prototype with only the core functions
this is then presented to users as early
as possible to test what they think
because it is imperfect even friends
give their honest opinions the goal fail
fast but collect intelligent information
so you can improve while going forward
they steal best practices Picasso
apparently said the good artists borrow
great artists steal learning
organizations study others steal best
practices and then implement them fast
the newspaper The Economist took advice
from George Orwell it said it is never
used jargon if everyday English works
printing manufacturers stole the razor
and blades business model from Gillette
selling printers cheap but ink expensive
they cultivate a common vision a
learning organization prospers when all
members share a common vision that way
employees can understand the importance
of their role connect the dots and
develop systems thinking when goals are
clear regulations can be reduced and
people can create their own personal
benchmarks of success this reduces
bureaucracy Authority and corruption
salesmen and authors Zig Ziglar once
wrote the only thing worse than training
people and having them leave is not
training them and having them stay at a
learning organization education happens
as a side product of working together as
everybody learns from each other to
adapt to whatever the future might bring
if you like our videos and want to
support our channel visit us at
patreon.com slash sprouts and see if you
want to donate just $1 with your support
we plan to create many more minute
videos about learning and education
[Music]